on fait le point avec andré l'accord est
ministre des affaires municipales et de
l'habitation bonjour madame la forêt oui
bonjour madame mori bonjour frappé la
frapru estime que près de 400 ménages
québécois se sont retrouvés sans logis
le 1er juillet l'an dernier vous
attendez vous à ce que ce soit encore
pire cette année c'est certain c'est à
lyon encore une fois on a pris tous les
moyens parce que moi je suis je suis
partie d'ailleurs en tournée dans toutes
les municipalités dans les offices
d'habitation pour vérifier comment ça se
passait parce qu'on a déployé notre plan
d'action plan d'action la hauteur de 60
millions pour aider les locataires
justement avoir des programmes pour se
loger
on l'annoncé très très tôt pour qu'on
puisse déployer programme mais aussi
qu'on puisse travailler avec nos
municipalités dont oui je fais la
tournée parce qu'on est plus sensible
vous le savez la pandémie dans tous les
secteurs ça a été assez particulier en
habitation aussi mais on a donné les
moyens aux offices d'habitation pour
loger les locataires évidemment donc moi
j'étais la semaine passée par exemple
dans le québec aux alentours cette
semaine j'étais à montréal aux alentours
aussi de rebondir saint-hyacinthe laval
alors c'est important de voir quand même
que nos directeurs directrices de fils
d'habitations ont le contrôle la
situation c'est certain cette année
c'est particulier à cause du télétravail
par exemple les gens vous déménagez à
cause des étudiants qui ont quitté la
ville de montréal pour aller en région
mais on a pris mes moyens je crois que
ça va bien se passer c'est certain que
tous les jours la société d'habitation
au travail
nos services sont ouverts tous les jours
et je m'attends à ce que ça se passe
bien honnêtement mais comme comme pour
dit il faut quand même être disponible
les municipalités ont eu deux millions
pour aider les offices d'habitation dont
il ya personne cette année moi je
l'espère je vraiment pas de personnes se
retrouvent à la rue parce qu'on a pris
les moyens
puis on veut et les locataires à 10 le
jso c'est certain mais il reste qu'on
entend des histoires de pénurie dans
toutes les villes que vous avez nommé il
ya des gens qui n'arrivent pas à se
trouver un logement est ce qu'on peut
parler d'une crise de l'abordabilité
dans ce cas là mais quand on parle de
crise de logement par exemple c'est
quand taux d'inoccupation est en votes
2%
c'est certain que présentement au québec
on a un taux d'inoccupation deux points
7 % ce que vous dites est important voir
que les gens qui ont besoin de logements
foule villa mais il faut demander de
l'aide parce que c'est certain qu'on
peut pas aller chercher des gens dans
leur logement
maintenant je vais là mais demander de
l'aide
appelez vos offices d'habitation parler
avec votre municipalité
et oui on va vous aider parce que je
donne un exemple à montréal on avait 477
demande
et voyez-vous quand je suis passé hier
on avait on était rendu à 80,88 de aussi
et mais les dossiers sont tous en
accompagnement donc on est parties
communes de 477 on est descendu à 88
demande et c'est d'être des gens qu'on
va accompagner parce que les gens ont
demandé de l'aide
moi ce que je dis aux gens à tous les
locataires du québec on va vous
accompagner des municipalités sont là
parce que même les municipalités sont
prêtes à aider par exemple pour loger
des gens l'hôtel en attendant un
logement ou encore mais entreposée les
meubles parce que c'est certain qu'il ya
même des propriétaires qui vont attendre
le 1er juillet pour libérer des
logements mais deux mondes et de l'est
depuis cette année c'est particulier on
a offert 60 millions on veut aider on
est disponible et en plus nos critères
sont beaucoup comment je pourrais dire
sont assouplies alors des clientèles
vulnérables
on veut aider des femmes en situation de
violence oui on veut les aider des gens
que ça peut peut-être pas tout à fait 12
mois 2 sont ici au québec on veut boulot
j'ai alors vraiment nos critères l'on
établit tous les critères pour essayer
de logique tout le monde mais il faut
demander de l'aide pour lever la main on
est prêt le gouvernement était à
l'écouté et évidemment moi je pense que
si je regarde toutes les offices
d'habitation et les municipalités jarre
est maintenant encore une rencontre avec
les municipalités du québec
ben je pense que ça honnêtement je veux
pas toujours les doigts mais on a le
contrôle puis on voit bien loger nos
gens au québec donc on a pris les moyens
c'est sûr que c'est quand même 60
millions qu'on a investi mais c'était
important de l'investir pour des
programmes supplément au loyer comment
je pourrais dire d'aider les programmes
pour
donner la possibilité d'offrir des
logements à des locataires partout au
québec mais on travaille fort les maires
et mairesses aussi je remercie drama
réalité tout le monde et en actions mais
il comprend que de l'aide à court terme
à plus long terme le réseau québécois
des obnl d'habitation dit qu'il faut
appuyer sur l'accélérateur faudrait
construire douze mille logements sociaux
qui sont en attente après ça 5000 autres
par année est-ce qu'on serait capable
d'atteindre ces niveaux là pour avoir
plus de logements sociaux
c'est certes et madame aurait en
nettement moins 15 soldats en poste
on avait annoncé que quinze mille
logements et est annoncée n'était pas
construit avec nous c'est sûr que l'on
ose dépêche on se dépêche là maintenant
de 6600 construit on a quand même eu un
retard de deux mois qu à pandémie à
cause de construction mais maintenant
moi je peux dire que sur les quinze
mille qui était annoncé ben nous on les
construit fait que c'est ce qu'il faut
ce dire le gouvernement prend ses
responsabilités mais oui vous avez
raison il faut travailler sur l'offre
alors oui on travaille sur l'offre ont
construit très rapidement mais aussi on
a nos programmes notre programme accès
logis qui appartient au ministère des
affaires municipales les habitations
avec les seiches lui la société
d'habitation du québec et on revoit
aussi programme pour avoir un meilleur
programme avec les municipalités avec
nos propriétaires qui veulent construire
des immeubles
alors dites vous que tous les moyens
sont les moyens sont aubry et c'est pas
vrai le cette année 1er juillet moi je
me croise les doigts il faut absolument
qu'on trouve des logements tout le monde
mais tout le monde collabore même les
grandes villes de montréal québec la
ville de québec d'ailleurs je
rencontrais son directeur de fils et
tous les gens les gestionnaires sont en
contrôle maintenant les locataires de
demander de l'aide c'est sûr qu'on peut
pas aller vous chercher dans vos
appartements mais le gouvernement vous
entendu on va vous logique on va vous
aider ça c'est certain
merci beaucoup madame la forêt merci à
vous merci à vous madame morin pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit
oh